Mercedes has presented its new a-class
in Amsterdam the original version was a
bit of a flop unstable in the curves and
notoriously failed the elke test they
solved the problem by giving it the ESP
making it the first compact with the
electronic stability programme mercedes
invited 450 journalists to the unveiling
of the fourth generation of the a-class
in Amsterdam
Daimler Group chief designer Gordon
Wagoner says it is always exciting when
a new baby is born it had been in the
works for five years and had only ever
seen it in a artificial context in our
design studios this is truly a new
generation of this progressive car the
suspense grew and grew finally the
moment Caine
and here it is our all-new a glass the
original a-class was tall and boxy and
unstable since the third generation that
has no longer been an issue generation
four has been designed from scratch it
is a direct challenge to the Volkswagen
Golf market leader in the compact class
at least in Germany many manufacturers
have sought to topple it and so far
failed the new Mercedes has packed with
high-tech designer Gordon Wagner says
his newborn baby is a fantastic car it
is all new the aim was to create the
next generation of the progressive idea
that made the a-class so successful it
didn't add lines on the body they
streamlined it they stripped things away
if they liked the result they stripped
more away there is no product as complex
as a car that's why it's so exciting it
starts with the exterior proportions and
motifs I'm a [ __ ] fun except
paparazzo on 4 X 18 V on some helped
ease the fears can't face nice and
aggressive and the interior looks really
high-end upscale like prestige models
the new generation a-class is miles
ahead of the competition
[Music]
hey Mercedes yes please change the
ambient light color to red ok I'm
changing the color it is a first for
Mercedes to introduce new technology in
the a-class usually reserved for its top
model like the s-class other
manufacturers such as Ford have long
pursued such a strategy as a way to lure
younger people to buy their cars this
must receive each development head Olek
Alenia says the technology has to be
intuitive and easy to use it has to look
good and fulfil all the requirements all
imaginable use cases for a connected car
such as navigation receiving calls and
ambient entertainment a-class comfort
even rivals s-class comfort you can get
seats that massage you as you drive LED
interior lights and lots of different
colours and there are of course loads of
safety features a chairman dieter said
she says the latest generation a-class
has brought down the average age of his
buyers by about 10 years that is a huge
advance although the new a-class looks
pretty grown up and mature it still
appeals to a younger crowd but not only
we are addressing a broad audience young
families and singles of course is
cooking following there's a so humor for
median of a nutshell feeder signals a
new way class is four metres 42 in
length 12 centimeters longer than the
last version the cockpit is more
spacious and the trunk has grown 30
litres to 370 V a class boasts entirely
new engines and both gasoline and diesel
versions have particulate filters
[Music]
the a-class will be presented to the
public at the Geneva Motor Show next
month
that's when Mercedes will reveal the
price tag the a-class is set to go on
sale this spring
[Music]